Premier jour de tournage et moins de 3 mois.
C'est parti pour 3 semaines...
3 semaines très intenses.
Et toi, tu te branlais avec ma bite.
Vomi, stress...
On se disait: "Merde, quand est-ce qu'on fait du cinéma, quoi ?"
De perdre les membres d'une équipe c'est...
Garer les décors dans une avenue...
Les séquences ont été filmées dans des conditions extrêmes.
Il fait une crise d'angoisse le mec.
Ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a pas dormi.
On a fait un film en condition extrême.
Et l'épée s'est démantelée.
Comme nous trois... Ecrire un long métrage, on l'a jamais fait.
Juste après le Saint-Honoré, on était très fatigué.
Surtout Raph...qui avait donné encore plus que nous.
On n'a pas forcément continué la fin de saison.
On avait prévu avec Suricate parce qu'on était assez fier de...
ce qu'on avait fait,on s'est dit: "Ah c'est... C'est bien !"
Quand même de finir l'année sur un... sur une longue vidéo comme ça.
On est ressorti de là... épuisé.
Super content... de ce qu'on a fait. On a fait des... On a fait la projection etc...
Et les gens ont beaucoup aimé et le film, le sketch même a beaucoup mieux marché que... ce qu'on espérait.
On n'avait pas envie directement de faire une saison 3 sur le même...
Le même processus, quoi. On s'est dit: "Bon..."
On va peut-être pas s'amuser autant sur la saison 3 donc...
autant faire une petite pause.
Avec Raph, on a travaillé ensemble sur une série et du coup on s'est vu un peu plus.
Et... Et un soir, on était complètement ivre dans un bar...
Et... Et on parlait cinéma. On se disait... Pour une énième fois, on se disait qu'on avait envie de faire des long métrages.
On se disait: "Merde... Quand est-ce qu'on fait du cinéma, quoi ?"
Enfin genre, on... On en rêve depuis qu'on a 12 ans...
Quand est-ce qu'on pourra en faire ?
On a eu une révélation, ce soir là. On s'est dit: " Oui, pourquoi on n'y a pas pensé plus tôt ?"
Pourquoi on n'a pas eu... Avoir le courage de tenter ?
Et quand on s'est réveillé le lendemain, en fait...
On y repensait beaucoup, on s'est envoyé des textos.
On en a reparlé à Vincent...
Et puis là, ils sont revenus vers moi en me disant: "Hé, on aimerait bien faire..."
"Refaire du Suricate mais en... Plus gros, 'fin..."
"Comme du "Fantôme de Merde", mais peut-être plus long... Si tu es chaud."
Donc moi, j'ai dit: "Non."... Parce que ça me paraissait complètement infaisable et fou.
Là, il a pas hésité longtemps.
Il a pas hésité longtemps, il a dit: "Ouais, ok."
Il a juste dit, si je me souviens, il a juste dit...
Il faut juste la bonne histoire.
Il faut juste le bon truc... Faisons pas un film pour faire un film...
Trouvons ensemble, tous les trois, une idée qui nous plait...
Le fait de se poser tous les trois derrière une table...
Les idées ont fusé.
Je sais pas... 6, 7 pitchs, le film un peu différent...
En tête, qui nous plaisait déjà un petit peu.
On s'est dit: "Là, déjà, le projet commençait à vivre, en fait."
On commençait à se dire: "Ok..."
"Là, l'envie de faire un film est vraiment présente."
On a pas encore... On sait pas encore laquelle de ces idées on va faire mais...
On a envie d'en faire un.
Et donc du coup, on s'est dit qu'on allait contacter...Julie Coudry...
Qui est donc... qui est devenue, du coup, la directrice de production sur le projet.
C'est vrai que... Je travaillais sur la prépa de Badass, de McFly et Carlito...
Et ils m'ont expliquée...qu'ils avaient envie de faire un film...
Et qu'ils voulaient le faire avec moi.
J'ai réfléchi à peu près 4 secondes et...
Et je leur ai répondu tout de suite... Que oui, j'étais partante.
On a commencé à réfléchir à des trucs, ensemble...
Notamment au financement.
Et l'idée, en gros, c'était d'arriver dans le bureau d'Adrien Labastire, donc...
Producteur de Golden Moustache.
Avec un... Un projet, entre guillemets, quasiment clé en main.
Moi, je pensais qu'ils allaient me proposer de faire une ou deux vidéos, un truc comme ça...
Et ils nous ont dit, enfin ils m'ont dit: "Voilà, notre projet, ce serait plutôt de faire... Une seule vidéo..."
"Très longue... Un film." Donc j'ai un peu tiqué au départ sur le...
Parce que je me suis demandé: "Mais... Comment réaliser, les comédiens... Le film en ce moment, le budget etc..."
Aujourd'hui, quand on fait un programme audiovisuel, en général on...
Le financement est assez calibré.
Nous, notre problème c'est que...
On voulait faire un film...
Sur Internet, gratuit pour le consommateur, c'est...
Ça n'existe pas.
Donc il fallait réfléchir à des modes un peu alternatifs de financement.
On l'a financé à 80% par placements de produits...
On a également complété avec une petite sortie en salle...
Qui rapporte assez peu d'argent.
Et le but du jeu là, c'est d'arriver à l'équilibre financier.
On espérait pas gagner de l'argent mais on espérait...
Pas trop en perdre, en fait.
Dans leur démarche, il y avait un côté...
On va faire un film pour notre public, pour notre génération...
Avec les moyens du bord.
On se débrouillera, en mettant de l'huile de coude...
Pour remplacer l'absence de financement.
C'était exactement le genre de projet...
Que j'avais envie de faire en tant que producteur.
Et donc j'ai dit oui.
Le plus fou c'est qu'Adrien Labastire a dit: "Go."
Et on avait une... Ouais... Un micro-pitch, quoi.
Vraiment... De... Ah, et si les gens ils changeaient de corps, en gros.
C'est un peu ça, et si les gens ils changeaient de corps...
Un peu tout le temps.
Julie nous avait dit: "Faut qu'il ait un nom ce projet."
On peut pas appeler le projet de vouloir faire un film dans...
Juste pour les mails, pour dire: "Ça parle de ça."
Et du coup, on s'est dit: "Bah appelons-le Chantal."
On voulait pas se stresser...
Donc on voulait pas dire: "On bosse sur un film."
On s'est dit: "On bosse sur Chantal." Ça va, c'est plus cool.
C'était notre projet secret mais...
C'était pas non plus...
On avait pas pour projet d'envoyer un missile sur un pays donc c'était pas trop trop grave.
Avant que ça s'appelle Chantal...
Le premier nom de code, que j'ai proposé, c'était "Droit dans le mur".
Je l'ai appelé: DDM, donc "Droit dans le mur".
On s'est imposé un calendrier qui était très serré...
Volontairement...
Parce que... On le faisait avec peu d'argent...
C'est un projet ambitieux, on s'est dit: "Faisons-le, du coup, spontanément."
C'était: "Ah, on a peu de temps, il faut trouver vite une idée, vite une idée pas chère."
"Ah, vite un sketch qui coûte 100 euros."
Donc là, c'était un peu pareil, on s'est dit: "Bon bah, continuons sur la même lignée, que les saisons 1, saisons 2."
"Fixons-nous, nous-même, une commande en fait."
Julien, ça parlera de quoi ?
Ah bah, on s'est pas trop, on verra...
Dans 6 mois, on saura.
J'espère qu'on saura...
Des transferts, des transferts corporels.
C'est le, pour l'instant, c'est le... C'est le mot clé.
On saura le titre.
On était en mars, à l'époque.
Et on s'est dit: "Ok, on aimerait qu'il sorte en septembre."
Donc ça nous laisse 3 mois d'écriture...
3... Semaines de tournage...
2 mois de montage...
Pour les créatifs, c'est une bonne chose de se fixer des délais courts...
Ça permet de mobiliser leur énergie...
Sur un moment précis...
Ceci dit, c'est la pire des contraintes en fait, donc...
Et à priori, il n'y avait aucune raison de le faire donc...
Après, moi je respecte leur... Leur envie de faire les choses comme ça, mais je...
Ça aurait pu prendre 6 mois de plus, à mon avis.
Au début, on a essayé vraiment de partir sur 3 personnages...
Qui avaient pris... 3 enveloppes différentes.
On s'est dit: "Ah bah ce serait cool, et puis en fait, il pourrait avoir des vieux."
Puis... On pourrait avoir n'importe quel âge, n'importe quelle couleur...
C'était ce que permettait notre concept...
D'intéressant, c'était: "Bah on va jouer une petite famille, en fait, tous les trois."
Et ça, ça nous plaisait beaucoup.
On savait qu'on allait bah, traiter d'un couple parce qu'on se disait : "Bah trop cool avec cette idée, putain."
Julien et moi, on peut jouer un couple, quoi... Jouer un couple hétéro...
Mais dans les corps de deux mecs... Et si y'avait un mec...
Un mec barbu, en costard, qui pleure à côté, tu vois...
Et en fait, il dit: "J'ai perdu ma... Maman, etc..."
Ça nous a fait rire de se dire: "Putain, un mec de 30 ans pleure comme un bébé, et en fait, c'est un bébé à l'intérieur."
J'ai une petite demande à faire, à...
A vous qui êtes... Les Suricate du futur...
Le film, il ressemble à quoi ? C'est plutôt un "Shaun Of The Dead" ?
Ou c'est plutôt "Matrix" ?
Où on en est en un mot ?
La mort !
C'est 2 mots.
Tu veux voir le scripte ?
Allez ! Montre-nous le scripte...
Accrochez-vous !
Suricate, tiret...
Les gens intelligents feraient une histoire simple.
Genre, on mettrait des gens dans une cabane...
Avec un monstre et...
Voilà, c'est un surviv... Ils restent dans la cabane pendant tout le film...
Et ils survivent, tu vois ?
Mais nous, on n'est pas intelligent et du coup, on s'est dit: "Viens ! On fait des trucs, avec des âmes... N'importe quoi."
C'est là que Vladimir Rodionov, notre directeur artistique, est vraiment...
Bah, nous a vraiment, aidé quoi...
Parce que... Il était là pour nous aider à être hyper efficaces...
L'écriture, c'était compliqué parce que il y avait très peu de temps pour le faire.
Donc fallait aller vite.
Fallait être efficace...
Un film... Au mieux... C'est 3 à 6 mois de travail d'habitude, d'écriture.
Là, il y avait 2 mois... 2 mois et demi.
Moi, je me disais: "Bon oui oui, on va tenter..."
Et puis, un moment donné, on a repoussé et puis c'est pas grave !
On tournera en septembre, c'est déjà bien.
Et non non, ils ont tenu, ils voulaient tenir seulement à tourner en juin...
Ils ont décalé peut-être d'une ou deux semaines par rapport au planning original, quoi.
C'était super tendu, à l'écriture.
Sans lui, on n'aurait pas pu écrire un film du tout.
Parce qu'il est assez stricte sur...
Ses méthodes d'écriture, sur...
Comment traiter une idée.
Première... Etape...
Définir les règles de l'univers.
On sait que, bon...
On se touche et on peut changer de... Et on peut changer d'âme...
On peut changer de corps.
Il y a multiplication, y'a la division...
Il y a la possession, tous ces mots là, c'est compliqué.
Toutes ces questions là, ça a mis du temps déjà à se résoudre.
C'est pas clair.
Et du coup, tu peux commencer à bâtir l'histoire mais tant que ton univers est pas...
Voilà ça se bâtit ensemble, tu...
Tu construis toujours, l'histoire, les personnages et l'univers en même temps.
On a essayé de faire un pitch, on l'a toujours pas.
Parce que notre idée, elle est tellement alambiquée, tellement chelou...
Qu'il faut... Qu'on voulait la résumer au plus simple.
Tu pourrais l'expliquer à un...
A un enfant de 8 ans et à une grand-mère de 77 ans, et que les deux comprennent...
Vraiment, de ce qui... De quoi il s'agit, quoi.
On a des esquisses de personnage quand même, on a une esquisse de Ludivine...
Qui s'appellera pas Ludivine, mais qui est l'héroïne...
Qui est entrain de se dessiner...
On a... Ouais, la forme... On a les va... On a les choix de corps...
On a... Donc qu'elle change de corps... On a l'âme qui se...
Détache de ton corps, qui est le point de départ, je pense...
Comme on se disait... Du truc, c'est... C'est ça qui permet à tous les autres pouvoirs, entre guillemets...
Je pense que ce qui nous manque, concrètement, c'est l'intrigue, en fait...
C'est une menace, en fait.
Bah maintenir l'intrigue ça implique d'avoir...
Un antagoniste qui ait la force antagoniste.
Et un des défauts...
Je sais pas s'ils auraient envie que je le dises, mais un des défauts du "Fantôme de Merde"...
C'est que l'antagoniste est pas du tout clair.
L'idée, c'était quand même de faire... De faire mieux là cette fois-ci.
Il nous a dit très vite: "C'est cool, c'est cool, c'est cool mais..."
Ils ont des enjeux, ils ont des problématiques... Qui...
Les personnages ont des choses à régler mais vous avez un espèce de méchant qui est quand même pas très développé...
Ou on comprend pas ses motivations...
Il y a... Il y a pas mal de...
Que si... On aurait 2 mois devant nous...
Pour refaire un séquencier, y'aurait pas de soucis.
Le soucis c'est que... Là... On n'a pas...
C'est 2 mois, il nous reste carrément qu'une semaine.
La résistance contre...
Contre un grand méchant...
Y'a... Il manque...
Encore clairement à identifier la menace...
Pour l'instant, cette histoire là, elle manque totalement d'enjeux.
Si on était qu'à ces questions là aujourd'hui, il n'y aurait pas de soucis, quoi.
C'est peut-être un soucis faiblard, si juste le mec...
Le gars, donc, il est moitié barje.
Le défi... C'était... La structure, en fait.
C'est que, raconter une histoire sur plus d'une heure...
Tu peux ennuyer les gens...
Tu peux raconter des choses qui sont pas cohérents.
On s'est vraiment compliqué la tâche, le premier truc, à écrire mille personnages avec mille arcs.
Et mille trucs à justifier...
Si on les met là, oui c'est qu'ils interviennent pas les mecs, quoi...
Ils les empêchent d'agir, en fait.
Agir qui ?
Les méchants ou les gentils ? Bah il arrive et il fuit la scène, en fait.
C'est juste, la menace monte doucement... Vraiment très doucement...
Pour arriver à ce point culminant...
Si l'antagoniste est pas fort...
T'as pas de danger, t'as pas de menace, t'as pas d'urgence...
Donc les personnages, il les végètent, quoi.
Les personnages, ils vivent leur vie, ils ont leur objectif mais y'a pas d'obstacle.
Très fort, il faut un obstacle plus... Très puissant.
Moi, j'ai pas assisté au tournage mais dès la première version du montage...
J'ai trouvé que les scènes avec l'antagoniste était super forts... Les scènes avec Milo a été super fortes.
Et là, j'étais: "On le sort, on l'a !"
On tourne dans 3 semaines ? Ouais.
Et ouais... Et ben, chaque fois, je me dis 3 semaines...
Là, on est dans la période où, ça bouge un peu mieux donc c'est cool, on a un peu repris du poil de la bête.
On est sur le... On a fini le séquencier donc normalement la V8 là, c'est la V Def.
Ça, c'est le séquencier... Le problème c'est que sur la page...
Et tu vois là, c'est une séquence et donc on décrit...
Tout ce qui s'y passe, tous les enjeux de...
De quoi parle la situation... Elle...
Où elle arrive, en gros.
On prend ça...
Et on détaille un peu plus, on rajoute les dialogues...
Donc, en fait, donc ouais tu fais fois... Fois 4 à peu près, donc ça, ça va faire...
Deux pages, tu vois. Donc ça fait déjà...
Quasiment 20 pages...
Et c'est quasiment la... Durée... Enfin la... Le nombre de pages que faisait le "Fantôme de Merde".
En fait, le "Fantôme de Merde" nous a permis de nous dire...
C'est possible de faire un truc avec une équipe restreinte...
Qui était à l'époque... Clément Maurin...
Et Remy Argaud, donc...
Son et image...
Alors là, c'est une petite réunion, un peu... Un peu qui mange tout mais c'est une réunion déjà avec...
Remand et Clémy...
Qui vont être les deux personnes... Qui vont rendre ça possible.
Du coup, on va essayer de leur expliquer ce qu'on a concocté et à quel point c'est...
Chelou et...
Et dur à faire ou compliqué à faire...
On fait ça en live avec Vincent Tirel...
Vincent Tirel de New York, NYC.
Hé là, c'est beau ça !
La police !
On a, on a un visiteur en appart' aussi...
Oui bah, qui est pas mal du tout.
Qui est juste à côté de... Qui est à côté d'ici.
De Golden Moustache...
Qui a déjà un charme à lui tout seul, en fait.
Appart' un peu bobo...
Arty, mais...
Vous avez de besoin de... ? Non.
D'accessoiriser tout ça... Comme ça, ouais...
Chambre à part, c'est super...
Ça l'amuse que... Pierrot il aime bien !
Si on choisissait ta parte...
On est pas dans le Golden Moustache, pour tout problème de matos slash de...
les comédiens, peut-être aussi si on a besoin de... Je sais pas... Peut-être d'aide...
De renfort, de laisser des affaires...
Du coup, qui fait qui ? on sait pas encore pour l'instant et...
Ouais, faut qu'on s'occupe beaucoup du casting... Mais...
Donc... Donc pour l'instant, on peut pas... On peut pas en terme de personnage.
Pour les comédiens, rien n'était fixé, en fait.
Même les rôles de Lily et de Ben, qui sont interprétés par Marsu Lacroix et Yoni Dahan...
Ils ont été...
Ça s'est décidé, peut-être, à 2 semaines du tournage... Quelque chose comme ça.
On voulait mettre tous les potes d'Internet dans le film...
Mais on voulait mettre aussi des gens...
Qui viennent d'autres univers, en fait.
Pour... Faut pas que ce soit un film 100%... Le LOL... Le LOL le Movie, tu vois ?
Internet 2.0 devient un film...
Donc on avait plein de gens, des Franglaises en tête, parce qu'on les adore et on...
On aimait beaucoup ce qu'ils faisaient.
Pour les Franglaises, c'est PV Nova, qu'on connait bien...
Qui nous avait invité, chacun de notre coté... Julien, Raph, moi...
A voir le spectacle...
Qui était génial.
J'avais joué qu'une seule fois avec eux, j'avais fait une petite apparition en Robin...
En "Super Heroes Hangover"...
Ça avait été déjà... Très très cool.
Pareil, une vidéo avec... Plein de monde.
Et juste, je suis un gros fan de leur travail...
C'est, franchement, le collectif que je... Je préfère sur Internet.
Ils m'ont appelé et ils m'ont dit: "Ecoutes, on a donc ce projet..."
"Qui est un peu..."
"Qui est un peu différent... On a pensé à un rôle..."
"Pour toi..."
Donc moi, j'avais déjà un rôle attitré et ils m'ont demandé le contact de plusieurs comédiens donc ...
Il y a... On... Trois autres Franglaises qui ont des rôles...
Dans ce long métrage.
Et donc, du coup, voilà on a fait passé des petits essais...
A 6... Ouais, 6 comédiens des Franglaises sur 11.
Et ils étaient tous fous...
Tous incroyables, donc c'était cool !
C'était la première fois qu'on faisait, surtout, passer des castings. C'était bizarre pour nous.
On a pris quelques scènes...
Clés... Qu'on avait déjà un peu écrites, on avait des V1...
Et on les a fait jouer...
Par différentes combinaisons de comédiens.
"Ah c'est dingue qu'il fait ça !"
"Ouais ! Attends, regarde, regarde !"
"Je vais achet... Des danseurs."
"On te l'avait dit qu'on supportera la grossesse ! On n'avait pas dit que c'était moi qui me tapait toutes les nausées, hein ?"
"T'inquiètes Chérie, je vais les prendre les prochains vomis, promis !"
On a tout les trois eu un coup de coeur pour Yoni...
Et Marsu...
On voyait vraiment le couple comme ça, quoi.
Quentin Bouissou nous a épaté sur tout le rôle.
Quentin, depuis le début, on l'aimait beaucoup. On le sentait bien en Milo.
Je crois que de tous les dissociés...
C'est les gens, à qui on a proposé en premier, en fait.
C'est notre casting idéal de dissociés... C'est celui à l'image.
Que ça soit les copains du web avec qui on a plus ou moins tourné...
Tous...
Parce que c'est tellement des conditions de tournage extrêmes, en fait...
Que... On est obligé de tourner entre potes...
On va lire tout ça... Il est très cocu ce scénario mais...
Il est très bien.
Faut le... Faut le limité.
De récréer des scènes, de s'approprier le dialogue, enfin...
L'ancrer...
On a écrit vraiment la version informatique.
On pensait aux visages, Sacha et Gwen sont des dissociés.
Parrainé par Monsieur Carlito...
Monsieur Chantal...
C'est vous Sacha et Gwen qui allez jouer, et du coup, nous on devient...
On a Lily et Marsu, on a Yoni qui fait Ben.
On a Milo qui est fait par Quentin.
Ça va ?
On a PV Nova, son associé...
N'hésitez surtout pas à dire si il y a quelque chose que vous comprenez pas pendant la lecture.
Elle sert surtout à ça cette lecture, c'est que... Le film est un peu compliqué.
Que tout le monde parte avec le même film dans la tête et qu'on a tous compris la même chose.
Faites attention quand c'est marqué: "Dans le corps de..."
Ça va être à vous de faire les répliques...
Si j'ai prévu un stage pour apprendre à dissocier son corps de son âme...
Moi, je sais pas faire !
C'est la main, quoi, comme ça.
"Suricate les Inutiles".
Scénario V8.
03 06 15
Intérieur jour, boîte de nuit vide, long couloir...
Une boîte de nuit vide, une mouche passe.
Une dispute se fait entendre au loin. Le ton monte, quelqu'un crie.
Là, c'est toujours à l'intérieur.
Iris ! Usule !
Je t'ai pas dit oui.
Foncez dans le tas !
Et mourrez comme des dératés.
Passage de Ben, coup de poing à Chantal.
"T'es sérieuse ?! Tu parles d'avoir des enfants et tu veux même pas d'un putain de robot-aspirateur ?!"
"La main de Gwen se déplie. Ben est obligé d'ouvrir la bouche pour ne passe faire posséder."
Oui ? "Ben et Lily laissent la place à Magalie, maquillé en chat."
"Pour s'échauffer, on va jouer à Chat !"
Bravo !
L'oeil du comédien...
Il coupera pas certaines scènes...
Il y a des comédiens qui ont joué, je sais pas, 4, 5 personnages dans le film, en fait.
Donc... Donc forcément il y a un moment où t'es perdu.
Pour la production, je me suis entourée de ma petite soeur, Elodie...
On s'amusait à prendre tout un mur de Golden et à essayer de faire un plan de travail le plus intelligent possible.
En fonction des comédiens... Des décors...
Et d'autres contraintes qu'on pouvait avoir...
Là, en gros, la dernière semaine tu as les 4 jours là et tu as un 5ème jour qui est là-bas.
Parce qu'on a peu de temps de tournage pour beaucoup, beaucoup de séquences.
Ça va être... 3 semaines très intenses.
Raph, Vincent et Julien avaient déjà repéré la machine du Moulin Rouge...
Dans laquelle ils voulaient tourner.
Et malheureusement, la boîte de nuit était en travaux.
On s'en ai rendu compte en repérage et peu de temps avant le tournage.
Toute cette partie là, elle va virer.
L'idéal, ouais, pour nous, aurait été d'avoir un peu de temps, un peu de liberté de mouvement...
Qu'on a pas, on a un tournage très light. Pour ça il nous fallait le temps de...
De full access.
C'est quand même une salle qui vit, donc vous auriez jamais eu une liberté totale, tout le temps.
Il y a toujours une utilisation de la salle, si vous avez vraiment besoin d'un silence dans la salle.
Ça veut dire qu'on doit...
Arrêter toutes nos activités pendant une semaine, ça c'est... Compliqué.
Peut-être, c'est ça le truc le plus envisageable c'est la nuit, mais je sais pas ce que t'en penses.
C'est fois 1 et demi, hein ?
Fois 1 et demi par personne ? Ouais, par personne.
Ah le prix ? Ah oui, ouais.
C'est quand tu fais dès 22h à 8, 10h du mat'...
On est 100% décalé, quoi.
Tu demandes aux gens de dormir la journée.
De faire leur nuit la journée... Et quand t'en as plein qui arriveront pas à se décaler... Et qui vont être éclatés.
Ce qui reste envisagé, c'est qu'on va tourner les 4 nuits...
On a les 4 nuits.
De nuit, on sera peut-être... On fera chier le moins de personnes.
Et on pourra peut-être plus tout enquiller.
C'est cool, une boîte de nuit vide. C'est nickel, on peut tourner de jour.
On va la tourner de nuit.
On a essayé de rajouter des étapes qui étaient...
Importantes, quoi, pour un projet de cette envergure.
On a fait quelques petites répétitions de scène clé...
Vraiment une après-midi ou deux avec... Pareil des comédiens importants.
Et une après-midi, tout juste, d'essayage costume.
Je suis content !
On est content.
J'ai pas envie que t'emménages.
De quoi ?!
Non.
Quand je vois déjà que j'ai passé une journée... Abominable !
Une journée abominable...
Donc ça va, on peut se marrer de temps en temps.
C'est bon ? Ouais.
Là, on se regarde.
Elle te parle.
Deux... Trois...
Je pense que je vais garder ce rush et on le met direct dans le film.
Anticiper un petit peu, on s'est dit comme on n'aura pas de maquilleuse, on n'aura pas de costumière...
Et d'accessoiriste...
Du coup, on leur a demandé de nous préparer plein de choses... Donc dans les costumes...
Et donc, on s'habillait nous-même par exemple, sur le tournage.
On s'est trouvé le style de Magalie.
Style de Mag' !
Il y a plein de petits trucs à essayer.
On le mettra jamais !
Mais allez ! Mais passe le là !
Si tu veux mais on le mettra pas parce qu'on veut pas la féminiser trop, en fait.
On sait que c'est une gamine, quoi.
Il est inscrit...
Ricatsou... Qui veut dire en japonais... Suricate.
C'est une râpe à quoi ?
Une râpe à tissu.
Ah, c'est une vraie râpe à tissu.
J'ose pas le porter.
Ouais, je te râpes la peau mon gars, ça va te faire bizarre.
Ça va te faire bizarre... Voir mal.
C'est bien ça.
Ouais, j'ai fait une crise d'angoisse la veille.
La veille, j'allais pas bien.
J'étais tout seul chez moi...
Y'avait ce gros tournage qui m'attendait...
C'était l'apnée, quoi.
J'ai pris ma respiration à grand coup et j'ai fait: "Ah"
C'est parti pour 3 semaines. Faut être à fond, faut tenir...
Et on se dit: "Ah ça va être crevant mais on connait."
"On l'a déjà fait, on va y arriver."
Moi, je me souviens que c'était plus le premier action qui était un peu bizarre.
C'était de...
De... Ça y est, quoi. C'est le...
Ça tourne, moteur. On est sûr, vraiment ?
Cri de guerre, allez-y !
Quand faut y aller...
Quand faut y aller... Faut y aller.
3 sur 1, première.
Ce qu'on peut noter sur ce tournage, c'est le rôle 1, je sais pas si t'as vu...
Un outil, pour... Etre plus fluide...
Pour le moment, c'est vachement bien. On va faire des plans séquence ou presque.
Des plans beaucoup plus longs.
Où la caméra tourne autour de nous, elle nous suit, elle donne un autre côté plus cinéma, sympathique.
Ben !
Monsieur, laissez-moi rentrer chez moi là !
Tu te barres, tu vois ? Ouais.
Et... Action.
Hé, je me disais...
Pour le déménagement.
Mais qu'est-ce que tu fous chez moi ?
Ben ! Oui ? Ta gueule, tu t'en vas !
Tu sors de là !
Ça va pas du tout se passer comme ça.
C'était une scène super cool à faire, c'était la première fois que...
Fallait que je joue une meuf, fallait que Julien joue mon mec...
En fait, c'est ma voix cassée qui a fait déjà avancer...
Ta gueule, je suis chaud.
Ça me va mieux !
Quand on se voit dans le miroir...
Et qu'on... Qu'on s'apprête à crier...
On avait pas vraiment envie de crier, on voulait plus crier.
On s'était dit: "Ça crie beaucoup, on a mal à la tête, on a tous mal à la tête."
On a juste fait...
On a crié genre 2 secondes...
Et en fait, c'était le poulet qui criait à notre place...
Ok.
Lâche !
L'appart' était...
Pas si grand que ça, donc on devait tout bougé à chaque fois.
En gros, quand vous voyez dans le film... Que... On tourne dans le salon, c'est que la chambre, c'est le bordel...
Clairement, il fallait au moins une pièce voir deux de plus.
Parce qu'en effet, on dormait au milieu des... y'avait la caméra là, tu dormais là.
Donc ici...
C'est la pièce où Raphaël Descraques a dormi cette nui.
Et où... Je vais dormir avec lui, ce soir.
Voilà... Y'a pas de place du tout.
Si on vit en permanence sur le lieu du tournage...
C'est-à-dire si on dort dans les câbles et les objectifs de caméra...
Quand on se réveille le matin, en 10 minutes, on est prêt...
Et puis voilà, et puis on peut tourner, quoi.
Faut le filmer.
Ah ! Bâtard !
Horrible ! Tous les matins, comme ça les gars !
Une planche de BD entière... D'un Comics fictif.
Et on s'apprête à le colorier comme des...
Des enfants.
On est d'accord, faut qu'on baise...
Et qu'on tourne à un rythme totalement effréné...
Mais... Non, non et que... Qu'on a très peu de prise...
Par plan donc voilà...
Faut qu'on se fasse confiance mutuellement...
On tourne un peu sous pression mais...
On a beaucoup de chose à rentrer par jour.
Donc voilà, donc... On flippe !
Peut-être on joue mal, peut-être c'est pas beau.
Ça fait parti... Ça fait du deal, en fait dans ce... Dans ce genre de tournage c'est que...
Tu tombes amoureux d'une scène...
Et tu en rêves pendant des mois et des mois...
Tu attends que de la tourner un jour, et un jour de la monter...
Et quand ça arrive...
Ça arrive entre 10h et 10h30 du matin.
Enfin, ça arrive... Tu as qu'une demie heure pour la tourner alors que t'avais rêvé de cette scène de ouf...
Action.
Alors ?
Sacha !
Qu'est-ce que vous avez fait de la gosse ?!
T'es qui, toi ?!
T'es qui ?!
Elle est où la gosse ?!
Magalie !
Ouais, trop bien ! Trop bien, ouais.
Ok, coupé !
Toutes tes scènes favorites...
Tu les cales en une matinée.
Et tu es là: "Oh mon dieu, est-ce que j'ai eu assez le temps de bien les faire ?"
Et au final, bah arrivé au montage...
Quand tu t'aperçois que ça marche, bah tu fais... T'es... Tu fais: "Ouf..."
"J'ai pas foiré, quoi."
Je suis super content de ce tournage.
Ouais.
On a un matos rentable !
Tu vois, où je suis vénère c'est... C'est moi...
C'est que j'avais pas pris conscience...
Qu'il était 13h30...
Donc on a perdu une demie heure sur le repas...
Je me disais: "On a le temps donc on fait ça bien..."
Et je pensais qu'on finirait à 13h.
C'est juste ça.
Mais en soit... On a le nombre de prise qu'on aura pour ce genre de scène tout le temps du film, quoi. C'est ça.
Ça va le faire ! Donc du coup, y'a aucun soucis mais par contre...
Je me chie dessus pour cet aprèm...
C'est la première fois qu'on sort...
De cet appartement...
En 4 jours...
Ça fait du bien de sortir...
Mais ouais, on est... On commence vraiment à monter les doses de café...
De plus en plus... Moi, ça va...
Le pire, vraiment, là... Il s'agit de Raphaël Descraques, qui met en scène... Qui joue...
Il tient vraiment vraiment debout mais ça doit être vraiment usant...
Fin de semaine... C'était un petit peu une... Une bouffée d'oxygène parce qu'on...
On a travaillé avec d'autres comédiens, en fait.
Et donc... Kyan et Navo ça nous semblait être une... Un beau clin d'oeil à "Fantôme de Merde"...
Ça nous fait tout le temps marrer de voir, comme ça, un personnage...
Vraiment à côté...
Qui est un peu comme un spectateur qui serait projeté, comme ça, dans le film...
Et qui ferait: "Qu'est-ce que c'est que ce monde de taré, quoi."
C'est des gros génies, ces gars...
T'en fais un, j'en fais deux.
Ouais voilà...
Ouais à ce moment là... C'est beau ça !
Ouais c'est bon, on le tient.
Ok, en place...
Silence...
Remy !
Magalie, reviens !
Un mec qui connait pas le concept de la frime...
Cette scène veut rien dire du tout...
Elle a aucun sens !
En gros ce personnage... Que fait Kyan...
Qui était dans le "Fantôme de Merde", subit à chaque fois...
Les trucs chelous qui arrivent dans notre scénario, quoi...
Tu vois, vu qu'on est très large...
Prends l'impact sévère... Plus fort l'impact ?
Le tout dernier ouais.
Ce serait bien qu'il soit un peu défroqué.
En fait, tu le remets pas complètement.
Tu le mets un peu à l'arrache...
Du coup il est vraiment, il s'est fait un peu engueulé...
C'est ça la raison !
Là ! Regarde-là !
Toi, t'es dans moi et moi, je suis dans toi là...
Yannick...
Depuis l'écriture, en gros, on a vraiment vu ça comme...
Notre zone sketch, quoi... C'est le...
C'est là où on va s'amuser beaucoup plus, où ça va partir plus dans de la parodie...
C'était l'occasion d'inviter...
Ceux qu'on aime bien, qui nous font rire aussi.
Et des potes...
On avait penser à vous y'a déjà deux ans, pour faire une émission de cuisine...
D'accord... Et pourquoi alors ?
Un talkshown...
De type, tu vois, "Touche pas à mon poste".
On y va... Allons-y !
Ça pue !
Ça pète !
Choco... Carrément choco !
Il fallait que Magalie regarde une émission à la con...
Enfin une émission... Type "Télétubbies".
Et très tôt, en fait, c'était le Palmashown qu'on avait en tête...
Pour faire ça, quoi.
Jamais ils feront une émission de télé...
Pour enfant... Enfin, jamais ils le feront...
C'est pas dans leurs inspirations en tous cas...
On s'est dit: "Mais nous, on voudrait trop les voir là dedans, donc viens dans notre télé, et dans notre télé fictive à nous..."
Ils sont dans une émission pour enfant...
D'accord là dessus, y'aura le texte ?
Ouais, ok.
Hey ! Salut les kids !
Hey ! Salut les loulous !
Salut les kikous !
Coupé !
Merci beaucoup les mecs !
Fin de journée.
La deuxième semaine c'est...
Plein de décors différents d'extérieur...
Et avec plein d'autres gens, quoi.
Chaque jour était différent, on tournait un truc différent dans un lieu différent...
Et le soir, fallait rentrer chez soi, dormir...
Mais là, ce qui était trop bien dans cette semaine là c'est que...
Julien, Vincent et moi, on tournait en tant que comédiens...
Que en fin de semaine...
La scène sur le toit du Grand Rex.
Ouais bon, on a commencé donc par le hangar, ça c'était cool...
On avait toute une journée pour faire...
Pas beauc... Pas tant de choses que ça, donc on a pu bien les faire.
Tu vois, et on a pu le faire avec le ronin, justement, en plan séquence.
On se baladait parmi les gens, on a pu faire des beaux plans.
On fait les plans très courts.
On fait... On essaye de faire croire qu'on a mille figurants.
Alors qu'on en a deux...
Alors là, c'est le faux.
Là c'est séquence immolation par le feu, très badante.
Très très badante, alors que juste avant on fait des vannes sur le prout... Et là des gens se brûlent.
Ouais genre comme ça, comme ça...
On va se mettre en place devant...
Finir sur toi...
Jetter le bidon...
Et la personne à côté de toi...
Qui pourrait être... Florent, va te faire...
Tu vois, juste faire comme ça.
Il va te le filer comme ça parce que vous êtes synchros, vous agirez d'une même personne...
Je veux bien, Remy et AK.
Je veux bien, on va faire une répèt'... une répèt' yeux... Vous traversez là.
Tu peux passer genre, peut-être avant Nico et nous, on passe devant.
C'est ça ? Tu sais qu'on pourra la tourner que très peu de fois.
Parce que dès que AK sera mouillé, ça va être difficile de se sécher.
On a qu'un caleçon.
Et du coup, ouais il va vous emmener... Surtout un peu de façon aléatoire et assez basse...
C'est un plan séquence où on doit marcher entre des gens à l'envers...
Ne pas leur rentrer dedans...
Si c'est possible... Et en plus c'est que moi, je tiens ça...
Et Raph, en même temps, il a une petite télécommande, et du coup il va pouvoir cadrer et faire des trucs qu'il veut.
En parallèle de ça, d'une séquence un peu sombre, on savait que y'avait...
La conclusion de l'histoire...
Et on se rendait compte, avec le personnage...
D'Adrien Menielle... Que oui, mine de rien, ça fait quand même une heure de film qu'il se balade en slip...
Et que ça... ça parait à peu près normal pour tout le monde.
Je fois faire gaffe à deux choses c'est... La dernière goutte quand je vais pisser...
Et des mouvements en trop...
T'aurais dû mettre un caleçon.
Je bouge une jambe...
Ça soulève de l'autre côté...
C'est l'exposition...
Testiculaire...
C'était un pari super risqué pour nous de se dire...
Les grands aveux de...
Des héros à la fin du film...
Vont pas se faire à travers nos corps, en fait. Alors que c'est des corps que t'as suivi tout le long du film, tu vois.
Et ce que va faire Lucien...
Il prend l'impact aussi...
Il va faire tête à gauche...
Tête à droite...
Et il va dire: "Lily."
Votre but à vous derrière...
C'est faire la même chose que lui.
Voilà, bon courage.
Non...
Deux... Trois... Quatre...
On savait déjà qu'on mélangerait le dialogue de cette séquence avec une autre...
Qui se passe avant la fusion, elle a écrit vite donc...
On a écrit des répliques qui sont un peu trop informatif, tu vois.
Tu vois, là y'a des flèches mais on a... Voilà à peu près la scène.
Ce qui se peaufine c'est un échange du dialogue entre deux personnes...
On est concrètement entre 6... 6 personnes.
On a déboulé sur le tournage avec...
Un dialogue qui nous plaisait qu'à moitié, on savait qu'on le retravaillait.
Globalement, je trouve qu'on a fait d'assez bonnes modifications et on a...
La plupart du temps, je pense, améliorer les scènes.
En les retravaillant sur place.
Lily ? Oui.
On est bien dans tous les corps en même temps.
Je crois... Je crois que ça va... Ouais ça va... En gros, ouais.
Lily, elle regarde par là, ouais.
On est dans tous les corps en même temps.
Oui, je crois.
C'est un peu compliqué, faut bien qu'on comprenne...
Qui est Lily, qui est Ben...
On a fixé un code...
C'est le plan le plus compliqué, genre.
Ben ? Ouais ?
Moi aussi quand je soulève, je pète...
J'en étais sûr.
On est très très en retard.
On est viré du décor dans une heure et demie.
Deux... Trois...
Tourner avec Baptiste Lecaplain c'était... Trop bien.
Déjà, il était super cool avec nous.
On l'avait jamais rencontré et il était super...
Abordable et trop sympa, trop content d'être là.
Pour le coup, c'était un des rares guest cinoche...
Qu'on ait dans notre film.
C'est compliqué Baptiste parce qu'en fait, il lâche 15 vannes à la minute.
Donc en fait, on a dû le refaire je pense 40 fois tellement...
Qu'on arrive plus.
La possession, ça se fait par le visage... Ouais.
Et du coup, tu vas lui faire juste, comme ça.
Tu lui tiens... Tu lui tiens derrière.
Et c'est toi, Baptiste, qui donne le mouvement... Qui donne la violence du truc en mettant ta tête en arrière.
Tu vois ? Ouais. C'est pas lui qui force.
Action.
Excusez-moi.
Vous avez l'heure ?
Oui.
C'était le dernier plan.
Avec Baptiste Lecaplain.
Je sens... La main de McFLy...
Tu dis: "Fin de jour, fin de tournage." Et tu peux lui faire la bise si tu veux.
Salut ! Bonjour et bienvenue !
Sur le plateau, le tournage !
Du prochain Suricate.
Catherine Deneuve qui a laissé...
Son odeur...
Son odeur corporelle...
Sur chacun de ces meubles.
Ce meuble en bois par exemple...
Les bois, imitation marbre.
Hallucinante !
Et ce magnifique portrait de Giscard d'Estaing...
Hyper mal représenté.
J'ai dormi 5 heures.
Donc ça va.
C'et les transports qui sont difficiles.
Quand on était sur la première semaine, on dormait tous ensemble.
Là, de couper le soir pour revenir le lendemain, c'est ça qui fait... Cette coupure, elle fait mal.
Là, on est dans un magnifique décor...
Tu vois, mais bizarrement il est plus...
Il est plus beau que... Qu'Adrien Menielle.
Improvisation !
On y tourne la scène du trader...
Qui est une scène importante du scénario parce que...
C'est le moment où l'héroïne, donc Lily...
Va pour tout quitter, tout lâcher...
A l'écrit, on l'a appelé "Le Trader".
Et on s'est dit: "Il nous faut du lourd !"
Il nous faut un mec qui envoie un petit peu...
Du charisme, donc... On a fait appel à Slimane Baptiste Berhoun...
Le talentueux...
Le virtuose, le funambule.
En fait, j'ai pas lu exprès le scénar'...
J'ai lu juste, Raph m'a dit: "Tes pages, c'est 60, 65..."
"T'es pas obligé de lire le reste si tu veux garder la surprise." Et effectivement...
Non seulement je m'en fous mais, en plus, je veux garder la surprise.
Comme ça, après au cinéma, je fais: "Ah ! D'accord..."
Ou, alors je fais: "Qu'est-ce que je fais là ?"
Au départ, dans le texte, c'était écrit comme une séquence assez baston...
On voulait, en effet, que ce soit un premier...
En tout cas, un peu d'action et un premier échange de coup, etc...
Le lieu est tellement beau et tellement fragile qu'on va éviter de faire trop de trucs, trop bourrin...
Tout ce qu'on doit comprendre c'est... Que je m'enfuis.
Et que je sèche Slim'...
Et AK...
Comme ça, et tu fais et je tombe sur la chaise...
Ou tu t'assois et moi, j'ai juste à faire ça et...
Tu détournes et... Et moi j'essaye de t'asseoir, ouais.
Si je sens que tu fonces vers moi, j'utilise juste la chaise comme... Comme obstacle.
T'essayes vraiment de me toucher...
Ça peut le faire, faut voir si ça rend bien.
Je pense que là on va... Faut vraiment faire une chorégraphie simple à mon avis.
Je pense pas que ça passe, c'est pas grave ?
Faut que t'abordes... Ça va mais je pense faut que t'amorces le mouvement pour que ce soit...
Que tu me suives, tu vois ?
J'ai peur pour Adrien qui se fait fouetter le dos et puis qu'il se prend aussi le...
Le fauteuil en pleine tronche, on va voir ce que ça va donner.
Même si ça me fouette, on s'en fout quoi. Faut que ce soit crédible.
Tes questions de tablette dans la gueule et tes questions de sauter sur un bureau...
Ça vient tout recréer sur le moment et j'aime trop ces moments là, c'est trop bien.
Et c'est le dernier plan de Slimane Baptiste Berhoun !
On a le décor de demain qui vient de nous lâcher...
24h avant, ouais !
Voilà, et c'est un décor qu'on a repéré il y a 3 semaines...
On a fait le découpage en fonction...
Et donc Raph est pas au courant ?
Pas encore...
Il y a un décor qui nous a lâché pour le lendemain, donc Julie nous l'a caché au début...
Et nous l'a avoué un peu plus tard dans la journée...
On avait pas de décor pour le lendemain.
Mais c'est tout le talent de Julie, c'est qu'elle nous l'a annoncé avec des solutions, déjà.
Donc la veille on a dû trouver... Demain, où on tourne ça ? Et c'est Eléonore Costes...
Qui a dit: "J'ai un appart' si vous voulez..."
Faut se débrouiller.
Là c'est le 10ème jour de tournage...
Ça passe trop vite, en fait.
J'ai l'impression que c'était... Qu'on avait commencé encore hier.
Mais donc là, la fatigue...
C'est un peu mal à la tête.
Là, on essaye de foutre en bordel l'appart' pour que ça soit l'appartement de Milo.
Donc on part sur une bidouille...
Faire croire à des stores pétés et essayer à peu près de cacher l'entrée de lumière.
En fait, je suis mitigé parce que tourner dehors, on a pas de chaud...
Contrairement à quand on est dans un petit appart' comme ça, plein.
Mais, il y a beaucoup de bruit. Hier, c'était vraiment la merde.
Et il y a beaucoup de gens qui passent et qui rigolent, il y a des voitures et des trucs.
Dans le cadre où on est aujourd'hui, j'espère que ça ira...
Ou faire les travaux qu'on n'a pas encore vu.
Ils sont au milieu et ils reculent là.
On a calé les éboueurs sur... Ouais c'est pas pour tout de suite, hein ?
Ils vont faire un peu le... Ouais ils ont un petit... Tout un petit trajet... D'une heure.
C'est bon pour toi ? Bah tiens, mate-ça !
Action !
Quentin a proposé un truc qu'il faisait avec ses mains pour quand il manipulait les gens et...
Ça rendait super bien, graphiquement c'était super beau. J'avais vraiment l'impression de tourner...
Un manga français.
Ta gueule !
Putain !
Ferme ta gueule !
Elle est trop bien !
Coupé.
Vu que c'est un duo...
Il y avait beaucoup de trucs à prévoir ensemble etc...
Et ça ils l'ont fait pendant le tournage, c'était trop agréable.
Voilà, c'est ça.
C'est ça !
Le voisin du dessus.
Ça, c'est d'eux, hein ? C'est pas de nous.
La journée est sur le toit...
On l'a préparé la veille.
Juste après le tournage chez Milo.
On a, comme ça, orchestré les petites bastons avec...
Le poivrier, du sel et...
Dans un resto.
J'ai fait: "Bon, voilà ce que je vois. Je vais simplifier plein de choses et à la fois, comme ça, on aura peut-être plus de temps pour..."
"Tourner et avoir de l'émotion sur la mort de Magalie, quoi."
Se remettre dedans d'un coup là...
Retrouver les personnages, c'est bête, mais on avait à peu près trouver nos personnages la première semaine donc...
Là, il fallait les rechopper.
On avait cette peur là, quoi. De pas retrouver les persos, surtout Vincent avec Magalie...
Qui est un personnage assez précis.
On est sur le toit du Grand Rex. On tourne la bataille finale donc c'est le moment...
Où Milo s'est réfugié sur le toit de la boîte de nuit...
Et Magalie arrive et essaye...
De l'arrêter, sauf qu'elle se fait posséder par Milo.
On a 41 plans à faire rentrer en...
Trois quart de journée.
Voilà, donc ça va être très sport.
On risque de se faire battre par le soleil.
J'espère que le temps sera avec nous.
Et qu'on va pas crever d'une insolation...
J'ai déjà eu une insolation sur un tournage là, sur un toit.
Ça fait mal.
Ça va ? Ça se voit pas ?
Ça va, c'est bon.
Ok, on est parti.
On essayait de pas trop bronzer parce qu'il restait du tournage après, donc on voulait pas se taper un...
Le teint de Bernard Montiel.
On était venu ici tourner... "Super Heroes Hangover". La fin de "Super Heroes Hangover" juste au dessus là.
Et donc, ça fait plaisir de revenir.
"Je sais mais c'est la dernière fois, promis, oui oui."
"Non mais je sais que l'état des lieux c'est demain, ouais je sais mais là, je... Suis à l'étranger, en fait. Encore une fois, je suis désolé."
Quand on est venu la première fois, c'était pour tourner les fesses d'AK...
Donc c'était un plan stylé.
Mais c'est vrai que c'était très court.
Et c'était frustrant, on se disait: "Putain, on... Mais pourquoi on peut pas faire une grosse scène d'action ?"
Et on l'a fait.
Tu sais ce que j'ai le moins envie de mettre ? C'est ça.
Et tu sues à environ 20 secondes là dedans...
En 20 secondes, c'est bon...
Ça y est, c'est bon ? Ça fait 20 secondes ?
Ça fait 20 secondes, j'essaye déjà de les enlever.
On savait pas du tout... Comment on allait tourner la séquence de combat, dans la boîte de nuit...
Et on tournait ce qui se passait après...
On va être derrière vous, donc faites le combat...
Tu vois, comme ça. Oui. Tu vois, comme ça.
Vas-y, viens on fait... on fait une esquive au ralenti.
D'accord.
J'arrive, je suis comme ça.
Ouais, non, faudrait que je le...
Faudrait que je fasse ça.
Mais vraiment comme ça.
Et d'un coup tu te jettes, je pense, tu vois ? Ouais.
J'ose pas être trop dans l'action si je suis quand même zen attitude.
Ok, coupé.
Ça va être bien.
Très bien.
Faut y aller mollo sur l'atterrissage en tout cas.
Non mais là j'ai fait un petit mouvement, en fait, mais j'aurai pu plus vriller là.
Vriller de côté.
Ça va.
Là, ça rendait bien.
Et je l'ai trop géré mec, c'était ouf.
Moteur.
Je me cale sur quand tu le touches.
Ça tourne.
Action !
Son seul... Son seul cri.
Son seul cri.
Ça va l'énergie ?
Ça fait mal à la tête.
Ça va ?
Trop content, il est trop bien leur jeu, il est trop bien...
En place !
C'était l'une de mes peurs.
Vu qu'on a écrit un truc un peu fantastique, un peu Dragon Ball Z etc...
Que ce soit pas crédible...
C'est pour les gamins qui essayent de faire des trucs comme ça...
Et en fait, tout se passe à l'intérieur. Leur jeu est nickel...
Les SFX et tout ça...
Je suis confiant.
Coupé.
J'ai plus d'énergie.
J'en avais pas beaucoup ce matin...
Là, j'en ai... Ouais là je ne...
J'en ai plus.
J'en n'ai pas, j'en ai...
Le mec est chanteur.
On est entrain de lui niquer ses cordes vocales.
En 11 plans... 11 plans de cri. Voilà.
Fin de carrière.
Justement... C'est génial parce que tu peux faire un peu ce que tu veux, c'est...
Tu peux, t'as le droit d'être bizarre.
Et ça, c'est vraiment génial pour un acteur de...
De faire, ce que tu veux, en fait.
C'est venu un peu comme ça pendant les essais et après... Il m'a dit: "Ouais, c'est bien, c'est intéressant."
"Fouille, cherche..."
"Un peu Joker like tout ça, machin." C'était...
C'était cool
Ouais, on s'est bien... On s'est marré. De toutes façons, faut que j'y aille là.
Action !
Lui, c'est une sale affaire.
Je vois qu'un seul homme capable de saigner autant dans toute la ville.
Il fait trop chaud et ça c'est noir...
Et c'est du béton.
C'est du goudron, pardon.
C'est un peu des deux.
Et du coup...
C'est chaud.
Parce que quand on a écrit, c'était pas l'été.
Alors on s'est dit qu'on mettrait des trucs chauds.
On aurait dû écrire des trucs en slip.
La prochaine fois, on écrit les mecs en slip, sauf que si on écrit en été...
On va mettre des mecs en slip en hiver.
Les risques du métier.
T'es comme une merde.
Sur la clavicule.
C'est le soleil attaque sévère, le stress aussi parce que...
Beaucoup de plans aujourd'hui et...
Et ben, le stress...
La scène de la mort de Magalie, c'était une des scènes qui...
Faisait le plus peur du film, et à la fois que j'avais trop envie de voir.
Et à la fois que j'avais... Très bien calée dans ma tête.
J'ai demandé à Julie...
Qu'on tourne en petit comité, on était vraiment...
Que le cadreur, enfin Remy, Clément et nous.
Et j'ai même demandé à Julie, et de toute l'équipe d'être cachés plus loin.
Pour qu'on se sente que entre nous.
Et du coup, ça fait partis de mes souvenirs les plus forts...
Mais...
Les plus durs aussi en même temps, enfin, il y a un mélange de tout.
Parce que...
C'était dur parce qu'on galérait...
A faire ressortir cette émotion, on voulait que ce soit crédible.
C'était un peu l'apogée, l'apothéose de notre projet.
On savait assez vite que...
Que la résolution de leur soucis se passerait...
Probablement par... Une fusion de leurs deux esprits, leurs deux âmes.
Dans un seul et même corps.
Et là, c'est le moment où...
Ce qui s'appelle un Money Shot, quoi, où on fait...
C'est-à-dire tu mets ton budget effets spéciaux là dedans.
Pour que ça soit beau et enfin voir...
Le côté vraiment SF de: on voit les âmes, clairement à l'oeil nu.
Et on les voit...
Fusionner l'une et l'autre.
Donc là, on va faire le plan sur la fusion des âmes...
Je sais pas si on le fera en deux heures... Je pense.
En gros...
On se touche et on... Nos âmes se... fusionnent, on les voit fusionner, se torsader.
Ensuite, entrer dans le corps de... Magalie, le corps de Vincent.
Déjà là, la scène qu'on vient de faire c'était pas une scène facile et on l'a vraiment expédiée...
C'est parti...
Le problème de ce projet, c'est qu'on a pas le temps de faire beaucoup de prise et donc du coup...
En fait, cette semaine m'a paru plus longue parce que chaque jour on changeait de décor et d'univers.
Alors que l'autre semaine, on tournait toute sorte de global, tout dans l'appart' etc...
Et du coup, ça passait beaucoup plus vite.
Je me suis plus rendu compte, genre: "Ah merde, on est déjà jeudi."
C'est vrai que là, c'était un peu plus long... Toutes les scènes...
Qu'on a tournées cette semaines, elles étaient vraiment cool.
Et puis, on a le droit de finir cette semaine sur ça, quoi.
De tourner ici, on a trop de la chance, on est dans une belle ville...
Et la semaine prochaine...
Vomi, stress...
Tout se passe bien.
Une boîte de nuit, 4 nuits. 4 jours de tournage.
Faut dire aussi, au rythme discontinue aussi mais 4 nuits dans le même lieu.
Donc à mon avis, c'est une synthèse des deux semaines qu'on a fait.
Première semaine, tu t'en sors à peu près...
Tu tires sur la corde, deuxième semaine tu tires sur la corde...
Troisième semaine, t'es en bout de course, quoi.
On savait qu'on serait fatigué, en fait.
On le savait, en fait.
Juste, on savait pas à quel moment on serait très fatigué.
C'est le début de la troisième semaine, on pourrait dire que c'est la fin...
Première nuit à la discothèque... Ça va être sympathique, ça va être funky...
On va faire du 20h, 8h...
Environ, je donne des...
Des fourchettes.
On va voir, ça va être un peu dur, je pense, pour tout le monde et après...
Je pense, vaut mieux rouler quand ce sera caler, quoi.
Je suis le frère de Carlito. Il vient de me voir pour la première fois, ça fait 10 ans que je l'ai pas vu.
Bah, chiale pas !
Chiale pas.
J'avouerai comme je disais tout à l'heure à Raphaël...
Que je sais pas encore exactement...
Lesquelles... De mes réplique je dis...
En Serge...
Et lesquelles je dis en Léa.
Parce que... Comme sur le scénario... Ils ont dit: "Ouais merde ! J'ai oublié de te préciser des fois que c'était Léa qui le disait !"
VDB quand il est arrivé sur le tournage...
C'est ce qu'il m'a dit, il venait de lire le scripte...
Et il m'a dit: "Putain, j'ai adoré..."
"Pas tout pigé mais j'ai adoré."
"Non Léa ! Rends-moi mon corps !"
T'es relou !
Et avant, j'était noir aussi.
Ta gueule.
Rester stoïque avec ce truc...
T'as l'habitude...
D'aller, réciter mon texte à 1h30 du matin.
Ça va s'améliorer tu vas voir, prends le rythme.
C'est le début qui est dur.
Moteur !
Ok, ça tourne.
Et... Action !
Puisqu'on est peut-être un peu fatigué, on se rend plus trop compte.
Il y a un mélange des phrases... T'as pas entendu ?
Alors vite fait,
J'ai dit: "Vous êtes marrés." Un mélange de "Vous êtes malades et vous êtes tarés."
On veut se marrer ? Transition...
Ok.
C'est une fin de première nuit.
Hey ! A toute à l'heure !
Salut, Vincent !
Bonjour.
Tu vas voir...
Oui ?
Tu vas improviser.
-On va y aller.
-Carrément.
Il nous reste 3 jours... 3 nuits de tournage.
Julie Coudry arrive un peu en bout de course et elle a enquillé avec des sketchs Lab...
Du Golden Moustache, des sketchs Youtube du Golden Moustache...
Et elle a enchaîné direct avec ce projet, le projet Chantal.
Je sais pas si je suis malade ou si c'est juste mon corps qui me dit: "Arrête, va te coucher."
Pour bosser sur ce film, c'est uniquement les gens qui avaient la motivation...
Extrême, en fait, quoi.
De... Parce qu'on a fait un film en condition extrême, en fait.
C'est un peu ça, quoi, tu vois.
Sur un plan du film, je tente une "Shining"...
Version junior, version enfant.
Pas sûr de ce que ça rend mais on verra.
Au moins, on peut se balader dans ce grand décor.
Je peux faire genre: "Non, non. J'en ai marre, j'en ai marre. Je me casse."
S'il te rattrape... Tu prends peur.
Et c'est Chantal...
Comme ça...
Ouvre bouteille.
Je suis entrain de déguiser une bouteille en sucre...
Qui est juste ici. Qui se casse immédiatement si je fais un faux mouvement.
Je pense que je suis la prochaine évolution de l'humanité.
On va tous être comme ça.
J'ai plus besoin de mes mains et ça tient.
Vous êtes prêts, les gars ?
Bah attends, fucking ready.
C'est bon ?
Je donne un premier action, il se dispute en off...
Et après je donne un top.
Quand on est en haut des escaliers.
Ok, ça tourne pour moi.
Je vais avancer.
Action !
Top !
Mais je te dis que si, je suis entrain de réfléchir.
Mais non, mais tu me laisses pas.
Tu as aucune idée de ce qu'on peut faire avec ça.
Mais ça va pas ?
Ok, coupé.
Comment ça va, William ?
Super bien, franchement ça fait pas mal du tout. C'est vrai c'est marrant.
Ça va la main ?
Parce que ça fait un bruit de malade !
Tellement peur.
J'ai pris une grosse prise de risque parce que...
On a fait de très beaux plans mais à la fois j'ai aucune marge de montage.
Enfin, j'ai pas grand chose en marge de montage.
Alors que d'habitude, j'ai plus l'habitude de faire des larges et plein de serré...
Pouvoir bien monter, choisir toutes les prises etc...
Là... là je suis assez restreint.
Mais on a tellement des comédiens de ouf et des techniciens de ouf, que je suis confiant.
Très confiant.
On tourne le dernier plan du film.
Juste avant que ça fasse "Cut".
Noir.
Générique.
Je vais l'appeler, je fais: "Magalie ?"
Et tu viens te placer entre nous deux, comme ça.
D'accord.
Voici, tu donnes ta réplique.
Bonjour à tous ! Alors aujourd'hui on a des nouveaux. Vous inquiétez pas, on va vous expliquer.
Ouais, de toute façon vous allez vite comprendre, on va s'échauffer.
Lily ? Là on s'ouvre.
Viens là.
Et tu fais la punchline, on le fera après, quand c'est le moment.
Et toi, c'est avec la capuche du coup.
Ouais.
Action.
On va jouer à Chat.
Avec ta capuche, énorme.
Putain, oui !
Vraiment, il avait un peu envie de vomir, il était pas bien et...
Et il avait beaucoup de doutes et tout... et ce qui... Enfin, comme nous tout le temps aussi mais...
Là, je vais enlever le ronin pour être plus simple.
Faut juste qu'on fasse pas de light et qu'on... fasse une mise en place comédien...
claire pour tout le monde.
Et ça pourra rouler.
Ouais, deux heures et demie comme ça, à 7h on a fini.
A 7h on casse ou on se cadre demain.
Ok.
On rentre en mode automatique où on exécute et...
On doit faire confiance à ce qu'on a écrit.
Parce qu'on a plus le temps d'y réfléchir et...
Et donc il faut qu'on...
Bah qu'on exécute ce qui a d'écrit, quoi.
On a fait un séquencier déjà, il y a longtemps et faut qu'on s'y tienne.
En revanche, il y a des séquences qui sont écourtées ou qui sont simplifiées, on fait moins de plan et on va à l'essentiel, plus vite, quoi.
Je suis pas... je suis pas hyper présente.
Je pensais pas que ce serait moi.
Je pensais que j'allais tenir.
Tu pensais que ce serait qui ?
Non, je pensais que quelqu'un d'autre allait fatiguer...
Montrer un signe de faiblesse mais pas moi, j'ai pas le droit.
Beaucoup de retard, on a surtout perdu...
Notre directrice de prod' sur le projet.
Julie est actuellement juste au dessus, elle dort.
Donc voilà, on va la laisser se reposer et on va essayer de...
De reprendre tout son travail...
Sans elle du coup.
On est entrain de perdre des membres de l'équipe petit à petit, c'est "Koh-Lanta".
C'est dur de rester efficace quand t'as une équipe qui se fatigue, quoi.
Quand vous regarderez ça, je voudrais que vous preniez en compte...
Toutes les séquences que vous verrez dans cette putain de boîte de nuit.
On a été tourné dans des conditions extrêmes.
Le fait que les deux premières nuits soient passées ça m'enlève...
Faut se dire: "Ah c'est fait !" Donc...
La montagne est moins haute.
Et puis je me dis...
Je veux dire: "On fait ça..."
On fait ça quand même pour s'amuser, quoi.
C'est pour s'amuser et c'est pour amuser les autres.
Donc au final... Si c'est imparfait, bah c'est pas grave.
Ouais, c'est juste que je me mettais une pression très forte de...
De on doit être parfait et tout et...
Si c'est imparfait c'est pas grave...
La seule envie de tout ce combat...
C'est quoi ? C'est que...
Julien dépossède Thierry...
Et s'excuse après.
Ouais ça c'est, J'y tiens à celle là.
Que Carlito prenne deux pains dans la gueule.
Un pain en plus, quoi.
Donc ce qui peut arriver c'est que, quand on descend là ...
Ils sont tous face à nous...
Je sais pas ce qui se passe.
Ce qui était dans la troisième partie...
On avait besoin que Ben...
s'émancipe un peu, s'épanouisse.
Et que ce soit un peu lui, qui sache aussi aller à l'affront et...
Qui aille au conflit, quoi, qui aille se battre.
Et finalement du coup, à la base c'était Lily qui devait le faire...
Et finalement, on a fait Ben.
Vu que Julien, Vincent et moi...
On est réalisateurs, scénaristes et comédiens du truc...
On peut réécrire notre film sur place, en fait.
En effet, dans tout le troisième acte...
On a pas de mini évolution, dans chaque truc elle fait un truc héroïque, tu vois.
J'ai pas tout en tête.
Je suis pas assez préparé.
Du coup, on invente un peu sur le moment.
On vient de changer au dernier moment de...
De mises en place, au début ça devait être Lily qui devait faire cette action...
Finalement c'est Ben... Et là, y'a une demie heure, trois quart d'heure, on s'est dit: "Bon, arrêtons. Il faut décider ça, point barre."
Timing assez précis je dois...
Me lancer pour que mon âme sort.
Donc le fistick, Magalie me le donne, j'appelle Lily, je le jette...
Je me lance.
Merci les scénaristes !
Y'en avait eu dans pas mal, des films avec Bruce Willis les scènes de baston...
Là, c'est exactement pareil...
Mais un peu au dessus de Bruce Willis, ils avaient demandé dans le scénar'.
J'avais vu ils avaient dit: "Ce serait pas mal qu'on le mette un peu au dessus de Bruce Willis."
Et c'est relou qui m'ont demandé de faire...
Mais ça je le savais parce que je l'avais fait dans "Piège de Cristal"...
Enfin, j'y étais pas mais j'avais maté dans le DVD du Making Of.
Et comme on n'avait pas de cascadeur...
C'était aussi sympa de prendre du temps, comme ça, sur les chorégraphies.
Alors on va avancer avec la caméra...
Tu deviens Belle.
D'ailleurs il m'appelle, je peux tourner la tête.
Magalie *Vou*... Belle.
Retour.
Ok.
Ça, c'est vos positions, ne dépassez pas ça si...
Si vous arrivez là, vous avancez plus même si...
C'est... extrêmement complexe, faut l'avoir en tête.
Ok.
Et Raphaël Descraques, il a une pige pour 6 métiers différents sur ce... sur cette scène.
Action !
Lily !
Très mal fait.
On a un petit plan séquence où... il faut bien caler les positions parce que...
Il doit se battre, Raph, avec un seul fistick.
Qu'on lui a jeté et du coup, il faut qu'ils puissent faire genre.
Sans donner un coup à la caméra et surtout aux gens qu'il doit taper.
Ah merde !
Ça va Thomas ?
Putain.
Ça va ?
C'est bon, tout le monde est bien... Tout le monde est bien.
J'ai fait, j'ai AS, j'ai du AS.
Mais avant... dans les autres prises on a fait ça à fond, tu vois.
Y'a ça aussi.
Ouais parce que c'est bidon là.
Tarantino nous a envoyé un texto, il nous demande des conseils maintenant.
Descraques a fait...
Et l'épée s'est démantelée.
Et des bouts sont partis un peu sur les membres du... Mais ça va, tout le monde va bien.
Merci Ben.
C'est Stefan Carlod qui s'occupe des effets spéciaux.
On travaille avec lui depuis la saison 1 de Suricate.
Et même pour moi, bien avant, puisqu'on est potes de collège donc on faisait des vidéos...
Dans notre jardin, ensemble.
Et donc du coup...
C'est lui fait la plupart de nos effets spéciaux depuis le début de Suricate...
On a toujours dialogué avec lui: "Comment toi tu vois les âmes ?"
"Qu'est-ce que ça représente pour toi ?"
"Quelle forme ça a ? Est-ce que ça doit fumer ? Est-ce que c'est ..."
On imaginait un peu une boule déjà.
Et, donc du coup, on a toujours beaucoup débattu avec lui sur...
A quoi ça pourrait ressembler ? Comment ça pourrait fonctionner ? Comment on s'envoie les âmes ? Etc...
Faut savoir que c'est quand même aussi les assistantes de prod' qui font le maquillage, ça, on peut le dire.
Oui.
Clairement, parce qu'il n'y a pas de maquilleuse.
Si on fait des captures d'écran et qu'on soit bien dans l'image, on voit bien qu'en ce moment j'ai un petit bouton, là.
Ça se voit dans le film parce que...
On n'a même pas couvert les boutons, en fait.
On a du bol.
Parce que... pas de maquilleur, pas de maquilleuse...
Tu vois en même temps, un bon herpès, tu l'as...
Un bon herpès de 3 semaines...
Tu l'as inscrit sur Youtube.
A vie.
C'est tellement beau. C'est ça .
Vous avez pas de maquilleur ? Non .
Non. Et bah niqué.
Je suis moche.
J'arrive, j'ai un peu le sang frêle de cette nuit...
Parce que j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont quand même assez cramés.
Ce qu'on peut comprendre, hein ?
Oui, je joue une mouche à la fin.
Seulement, j'échange, je me dissocie...
Avec une mouche... oui, oui, oui.
Et ça, c'est drôle.
Je pense, c'est de plus passer par le regard, et le sens, peut-être, qui... les pattes comme ça.
Faut pas que ça fasse trop animal, faut que ça fasse bien insecte.
Jouons la vraiment avec quelques répliques, des trucs de grands panneaux de...
Où il faut pas laisser cette mouche s'en aller, tu vois ?
Qu'elle est bien rentré dedans et qu'elle s'en va...
Ok.
Ça va improviser, tout le monde aurait la même réplique...
"Attention, la mouche !"
"Attention à la mouche, là !"
"Non mais la mouche..."
C'est ça, Thomas VDB par delà le matelas de connerie, il y a du génie.
Parez ?
Et...
Go mouche !
Oh merde... Putain choppe là !
Choppe là !
La laissez pas partir !
Cette mouche mais...
Envoyer, c'est bon.
C'était le dernier plan de William Pelletier.
Et c'était aussi le dernier plan de Thomas VDB.
Je suis trop heureux.
C'est génial parce que je peux mettre plein de bouts de pain de mie entre les dents...
On me dira pas: "Ah t'es pas raccord, mec."
Putain, j'ai fini, je suis trop content.
Je suis content parce qu'il est tard.
Je vais me changer.
Ok.
Et action !
T'es déjà mouche.
Moi, j'avance tout doucement.
t(
T'avances tout doucement.
C'était le dernier plan de Quentin et de PV Nova .
Bravo !
Regardez ! C'est parti !
Il marche !
Attention !
C'est super.
Merci.
Sur toute la dernière semaine, on a accumulé un retard...
En effet, il y a des séquences qu'on décalait de jour en jour.
C'était... pour Julie qui organisait le tournage...
Constante remise en question de: "Qu'est-ce qu'on tourne aujourd'hui ? Qu'est-ce qu'on tourne demain ?"
Le problème est qu'il nous reste une demie heure pour une séquence pour laquelle... on aurait eu besoin de deux heures.
Deux ?
Deux heures et il nous reste 23 minutes.
Ce qui implique qu'on va grossir la journée de demain et...
Et voilà.
On n'a pas pu faire rentrer le combat...
Entre Marsu, Yoni et Julien et moi...
Il était prévu...
Et... et au bout d'un moment, on s'est aperçu qu'il est 7h...
Et on fait: "Mais on a encore ça à tourner. On fait... on fait comment ?"
Et je vois Julien qui vient me voir en disant: "Ok, ok..."
"Donc on n'a plus le temps de tourner cette séquence, je...
Je vais faire des... Je vais réfléchir, quoi.
Et du coup, il allait réfléchir avec Julie et tout, et il est revenu en disant: "Ok."
"Ce que je te propose c'est que..."
"Là..."
"On finit de tourner cette scène..."
"On répète avec Marsu et Yoni un combat..."
Le plus important de toute façon c'est qu'il y a le départ de Milo et...
Et après c'est... Caler le combat, peut-être tourner le choix et...
On fera le reste du combat demain.
Si limite on a le temps de caler le combat et de tourner le choix, limite c'est pas mal, quoi.
Caler le combat en répèt' comédien et...
Et mécanique quoi, en même temps.
Et le départ... le départ...
Faut juste demander si demain, on pourrait avoir exactement les mêmes likes aussi.
Ça, on est pas.. on est pas. On peut être battu. Exactement.
Et c'est pas envisageable aussi Julie ?
Ouais.
De falsifier.
On était entrain de préparer une choré avec...
Julien... On l'a monté à Yoni, Marsu ensuite ils l'ont développée avec Raph.
Et ils ont vraiment calé ça au mieux.
En gros, ce qu'on disait c'est, genre, on est un peu en stand by comme ça, tu vois ?
Pendant un petit moment et il y a des trucs, peut-être une petite...
Attaque, une petite esquive,un truc et on fera: "Putain !" Tu sais, genre.
C'est moi qui attaque, on va pouvoir y aller ?
On va pouvoir y aller et tu vois, à chaque fois on n'ose pas et on fait... Je sais pas pourquoi on n'ose pas trop au début.
Oh putain, c'est chaud !
Là, il y aurait une écharpe là, je peux déjà tenter un coup de poing.
Ouais, là c'est elle qui attaque.
Ouais, tu m'as une première attaque.
Je l'esquive.
Et là, du coup je te rattrape avec l'écharpe.
Moi là je... Tu l'as jette en l'air et t'attaques direct.
Ouais, et t'es déjà dans le truc.
Plus ou moins en même temps, il y a Yoni...
Qui... qui essaye de me chopper et il arrive à me chopper le bras.
Et du coup, je me...
Là, genre en mode parachute, là je viens de me virer de mon...
Truc, tu vois ?
Dans l'idéal, ce serait cool de... Que ça reste pas trop en...
Là, on est vachement près.
Ouais.
Oui, pour moi pour... utiliser tout l'espace, en fait.
C'est ça, à partir du moment où on y va, tu vois...
C'est genre, ok...
Et donc du coup, nous, tu vois... nous, on peut prendre tout ça et vous vous avez tout ça, quoi.
Et nous-même, on a ça, tu vois.
Je suis pas sûre qu'on aurait réussi à la rentrer, et si on l'avait fait, elle aurait sûrement été mal faite.
Et là, le fait de la faire le lendemain, vu qu'on avait les comédiens qui étaient prévus de toute façon, le lendemain...
Là, on l'a faite plus vite et moins stressé parce que plus de problème de...
Plus de problème de l'horloge qui tourne.
C'est la dernière nuit, donc là, je suis mitigée entre...
Entre un peu la déprime parce que c'est la fin du tournage...
Mais d'un autre côté, je suis contente.
De savoir que dans quelques heures...
Une douzaine d'heure...
Je vais pouvoir me coucher et dormir pendant 72h d'affilées.
Humainement, humainement...
On s'est tous serré les coudes.
On a tous...
On a tous appris sur nous et sur les autres.
Ouais, c'était une expérience...
Vraiment hyper enrichissante sur tous points de vue.
C'était génial et...
Pourvu que ça se termine.
Je suis content...
Qu'on arrive à la fin du tournage.
Ça veut dire qu'on a réussi.
Mais là, tout reste encore à faire parce que mine de rien, en fait, on a une séquence de retard.
Par rapport à hier.
Il va y avoir une nostalgie, je pense, ce week-end. On va tous être un peu triste que le tournage soit terminé.
Mais... Mais à la fois content que tout soit rentré.
Je peux pas du tout te dire ce que je vais ressentir quand on finira parce que, là, je suis encore dans le...
Je suis compressé en moi, là, je suis...
Tout tendu de...
On dirait, tiens encore quelques heures d'énergie...
On donne tout encore pendant quelques heures...
Entre le jour où on a eu l'idée...
Du film...
Et le premier jour de tournage, il y a moins de 3 mois.
C'est chaud.
Le truc c'est que, là, on est déjà entrain de réaliser notre rêve, en fait.
On est déjà entrain de faire...
Ce qu'on voulait faire depuis tout môme, c'est faire un film, quoi.
Et on s'est donné la force, tous les trois, de le faire...
Quand tu élargies aussi à toute la team, tous ceux qui sont là...
Depuis 3 semaines...
Tout le monde est taré.
Et donc, ça fait plaisir.
De se sentir, pas le seul à avoir des projets aussi fous que ça.
Quand on voit que c'est, ça passe comme un miroir, en fait.
Ah c'st une gamine, elle fait ça.
Tu fais ça.
C'st bizarre ça.
Sabine, Vincent ?
Le regard, c'est Julien.
Qu'on machine tous les deux, en même temps tout ça.
Quand vous voulez.
Je suis dans les deux en même temps !
Ça marche très très très, très bien
On dirait que...
On dirait vraiment que Sabine est Vincent.
Elle a chopé le rire.
La démarche.
Léa dit: "Nickel, oh le joli coup."
Ça, c'est une des preuves...
Qu'on a écrit très rapidement.
Parce qu'on peut pas dire ça dans un film.
Tu le sens te dire: "Nickel, oh le joli coup." ?
Tu vois.
Clairement, les enfants ne disent pas...
Bah oui, parce que clairement soit je le joue comme ça soit... Non mais c'est pas possible.
Nickel.
Joli coup.
Et si j'avais tu demandes, si j'y arrive.
Jusqu'à une des versions très tardives du montage...
"oh le joli coup", c'était resté dans le montage.
C'était le dernier plan d'Eléonore Costes.
Dernier plan de Sabine Perraud.
C'est le dernier plan de beaucoup de gens.
C'est bientôt le dernier plan de nous-même.
Et le dernier plan du film.
C'est pour moi, ça.
Non, je vais déjà transpirer, je vais pas...
Oui mais tu vas sauter partout.
Mais non.
Non mais Clément c'est...
Bah si tu veux sinon on fait genre tous les dialogues en mode statique, on les fait...
On les enregistre, après je vire tous les HF et vous faites la bagarre.
Non. Bah alors combien tu mets...
Ça va coller...
C'est dégueulasse.
Ça va, Yoni ?
Reposé quand même, un peu ?
Ça va, t'as pu dormir ? Ouais, ça va.
Ouais, on a répété le combat pour qu'aujourd'hui on soit plus efficace.
Ça va le faire mais bon, on fait le combat du coup avant le...
Avant la scène du bar ?
Ouais.
Vu qu'il y a beaucoup d'action, ça a été à peu près découpé mais en gros, je vais quand même essayer de les suivre en faisant plusieurs valeurs et après...
On va resserrer de plus en plus, en fait. On fait très large et on fait un truc un peu plus large sur l'action d'un côté...
Et après on va faire des Pick up des moments... Il y a des moments essentiels...
Qu'il faut avoir pour la compréhension de la scène et de l'histoire.
Il y a même des couches... T-shirt...
Audi...
Veste en jean...
Veste violette...
Une petite couche en plus...
Cadeau.
Cadeau... Et puis on fait des choré avec ça, quoi.
En place.
On rentre ? Oui, non.
Quoi ?
Je suis crevé.
*Tac* sur moi et tu *tac* sur...
Et tu pars sur le côté un peu.
Comme ça, on tombe pas l'un sur l'autre.
Vas-y, on le fait.
Vas-y, viens on essaye vraiment là.
C'est bien. Vas-y, cool, ça va être ça.
Les ovaires, j'essaye de le dire ici.
Pas les ovaires, hein ? Si jamais on a des gosses, je veux pas de soucis.
Là, tu descends.
Et du coup, comme ça... Ouais.
Et c'est à toi de...
Il faudrait que tu aies tes mains devant quand même.
Tu penses ?
Ouais.
On prend pas de risque.
Comme ça, je t'emmène là. Je te l'ai envoyé avec la tête, tu sais que...
Tu sais qu'il y a toujours tes mains devant.
Tu récupères tes mains.
Ok.
Et je te prends pas la tête, quoi.
Bien joué.
Ce qui est fou, c'est que Raph est très stoïque...
Il reste pro.
Julien a le recul et se rend compte qu'il va rouler une pelle à son pote.
Bien joué.
Merci.
Enculé.
J'ai embrassé Julien Josselin.
C'était le dernier plan de Marsu et Yoni.
Merci.
C'était trop bien.
Dernier plan de Carlito.
Il est 7h34...
C'est le... la dernière séquence. J'ai barré tout le scénario.
Tout, tout, tout est barré. C'est-à-dire qu'on a tout tourné...
Sauf, la séquence 22.
J'attends plus qu'une chose, c'est qu'on dise: "C'est fini."
Je suis pas très content.
Ça veut dire c'est fini après.
C'est bon ?
Clap de fin.
22 sur 2, deuxième.
C'est une fin de tournage.
A la fois on est fier de finir, à la fois on est triste parce que c'était quand même une belle... une belle épopée, quoi.
On était content d'avoir réussi...
A rentrer ce grand projet. C'est 90 pages.
Qu'on avait fini de rédiger seulement 3 semaines avant.
Emu et fatigué...
de...
D'avoir fini.
Et d'avoir fini avec tous ces gens-là que j'adore.
Je m'attendais à ce moment-là, à...
A être totalement libéré... A faire: "On a réussi notre mission." Maintenant, on va aller dormir.
Et j'ai eu la boule qui est restée, en fait. Et donc, du coup, je me suis rendu compte que j'allais la garder encore pour plusieurs mois.
Pour la post-prod, pour tout. Tu restes noué.
Tant que...
Tant qu'il y a pas des gens qui t'ont dit: "C'est bien. On est content. Ça nous a plu, ça nous a fait rire, même un peu, tu vois."
Le montage, c'était cool.
Au début.
Quand je devais monter chaque scène...
Isolées...
C'était intéressant, j'aimais bien ce que je voyais.
Il y a eu des hauts et des bas mais...
Globalement j'étais super content.
Après il faut tout mettre bout à bout...
Et tu découvres ce que t'as fait...
Raph avait fait tout le taff de...
Tout le montage quoi, donc il avait fait...
1h30, il avait même 1h35 je crois.
De film... Et donc il l'a regardé tous les trois avec Vladimir, notre directeur artistique.
On est très content.
Parce qu'on voit que...
Ça tient. C'est vraiment tellement conforme au scénar' qu'on a écrit...
Que... Ce qui marche...
Marche et nous rassure...
Et ce qui ne marchait pas dans le scénar'...
Ça se voit, ça ne marche pas du tout.
Et donc on est... On est inquiet, quoi.
On en est où on a fait des erreurs de scénario, en fait, dedans.
On a dû les réparer après au montage.
On se disait: "On se rattrapera, on sait qu'on se rattrapera. On sait pas comment..."
Au tournage ou en post-prod...
Et donc là, en voyant la projo on s'est fait...
"Et ce sera en post-prod."
Je savais que le personnage de Lily, il fonctionnait pas dans le film.
Il avait un problème, il... Les gens ne comprenaient pas son choix.
Donc quand on fait à la projo test, les gens nous ont confirmé ça.
Quand Lily décide de tout quitter et de partir... On va chez le trader...
On comprenait pas ses motivations et du coup, on était pas avec elle, on la perdait un petit peu à ce moment-là.
On épouse pas son point de vue, en fait et c'est le personnage principal et c'est très ennuyeux parce que ça...
Ça pompe toute une partie de l'émotion qui pourrait y avoir dans le film.
Tu es moins derrière le personnage et même du coup, t'es parfois en retrait.
Tu dis: "Mais tu l'aimes pas trop ce personnage, tu le comprends pas." Et comme tu le comprends pas, tu l'identifies pas, tu l'aimes pas et...
Et tu es un peu en dehors du film.
Donc on s'est dit que avec seulement un plan ou deux de Raph entrain de quitter le lieu, ça pouvait suffire...
Pour montrer ça.
Et Raph aussi, dans les marches, entrain de lire le... protocole des Dissociés.
Et de se rendre compte un peu de sa condition.
Et de sa place dans la société, en tout cas, vu par les dissociés.
Et il y a vraiment une étape de réécriture qui se fait au montage.
Que, moi, j'avais peut-être un peu sous-estimée en tout cas, je pensais qu'il y en aurait une...
Mais peut-être pas aussi lourde.
C'est la séquence où Carlito nous parle des dissociés.
C'est un gros bout d'exposition...
Tu te bouffes que de l'info.
Pendant 5 minutes...
Autour d'un bar.
Les plans bougent pas.
Beaucoup de questions qui se posaient autour de Magalie.
Pourquoi elle a cette tronche ? D'où elle vient ?
Qui est Milo ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il a vraiment fait ? Donc on a fait une séquence animée...
On s'est dit que c'était peut-être un peu audacieux.
Et que ça pouvait marcher...
On s'est dit c'est cool mais il faudrait un bon dessinateur...
Il y a Vladimir qui a proposé Boulet...
J'ai fait: "Mais jamais on aura Boulet, arrêtes tes conneries. Il est jamais dispo. D'où il voudra faire ça ?"
Et le mec nous a dit: "Ecoutez..."
"Je suis dispo."
"En plus je suis tenté."
"J'aime bien. Tant que... Ok, on est chaud."
Il est super rapide, super efficace.
Talentueux.
Milo est devenu très dangereux.
C'est lui qui détient vos corps.
Le montage c'est ça, tu as moins de découragement puis tu rebondis.
Tu as une idée, tu...
Peut-être t'y arrives et là, tu sais pas si tu vas y arriver parce que il y a plus le temps, il y a plus les moyens, il y a...
La fatigue et puis finalement, on y arrive toujours.
Avec le compositeur Julien Bellanger, on s'est... Je l'ai tenu au courant très tôt.
Pendant qu'on écrivait le film...
Que, on avait besoin de lui.
qu'on aimerait qu'il fasse la BO du film.
Du coup, il y a... Dès qu'on lui a envoyé des bouts de scénario...
Même le scénario en entier...
Il a commencé à composer des trucs et ce mec est fou.
C'est un talent, il a un talent monstre...
Julien Bellanger...
Et une efficacité de travail de dingue. C'est trop bien de travailler avec lui parce que tu lui demandes un truc et direct tu l'as.
Une fois qu'on a verrouillé le montage...
Donc on s'est dit...
On n'y touche plus, c'est ça notre histoire...
Tant pis... Si il y a des trucs qui marchent pas.
Et il y a plein de trucs qui marchent donc faisons-nous confiance.
On a envoyé le montage à... Du coup, au mixage qui s'occupe du son...
Et... Et à l'étalonnage qui va s'occuper de l'image.
Ça bleui pas tout le reste de l'image, ça stocke que...
Oui, il manque du rouge.
C'est cool.
C'est bien.
Là, c'était notre image de base...
Là, elle est très contrastée, très dessaturée pour garder plein de détails.
Et après t'as le résultat.
D'habitude, on faisait l'étalonnage, nous, à l'arrache pendant le montage, tu vois.
Et là, on s'est dit qu'on allait prendre un étalonneur, donc c'est quelqu'un pour qui c'est le métier de faire ça.
Et on est rentré en contact avec Florian...
Et qui a été juste incroyable, quoi. Vraiment, il a transformé les images.
Les plans, on les a redécouverts parce qu'on les a bouffé...
Pendant des mois et des mois, pendant le montage sans étalonnage et là, il nous refout une couche de couleur de machin...
Il corrige des imperfections et...
Et donc, ouais, l'image vraiment prend une deuxième vie.
En terme de son, tu as des sons qui font *Boum*
Tu as des bons bruitages qui sont remis. Tu as la musique qui est au bon endroit.
Et ça a rajouté une bouffée d'air frais, en fait. Tu redécouvres ton film.
Tu t'appelle Magalie ?
Et t'as 5 ans ?
Elle est où la gosse ?!
Ce film représente vraiment...
Le parcours qu'on a eu...
Toute l'évolution qu'on a eu ces derniers années, en fait.
Ouais, dans ma tête, je le vois vraiment comme un season final un peu, Suricate. Même si j'espère qu'on fera autre chose.
Aucun de nous trois avait écrit un long métrage, jamais...
Pour tout le monde c'est la première fois...
Y'en a pas un où c'est genre: "Non mais moi j'en ai déjà un les gars. Et vos gueules."
Donc il y a pas de regret, on découvre tous.
C'est vraiment un choix d'avoir bosser ensemble...
Pour faire...
Ce type de projet.
J'aurai pu le faire avec personne d'autre.
Parce qu'on se connait vraiment bien.
T'es obligé de travailler avec des gens avec qui tu ris, en fait, tous les jours parce que c'est...
C'est généré du rire, c'est essayer de faire rire d'autres gens donc si tu te fais pas rire...
Ça marche pas, tu vois.
On est tous les trois aussi fous...
On est fous dans le sens folie, vraiment dans le sens malade.
Mais de l'avoir fait avec eux, c'est le meilleur endroit possible.
C'est le résultat qu'on espérait.
Au moment où on s'est lancé, en fait.
Enfin ,c'est fait, c'est... C'est fini.
On l'a fait, quoi.
Même si personne l'aime ce film, ça aurait pas été vain tu vois.
On aura appris énormément de choses.
On aura vécu une belle aventure et elle sera chouette.
Ça donne tout de suite envie d'en faire un nouveau, de développer un autre projet.
J'ai envie d'en faire d'autres.
Avec Julien et Vincent, avec tout le monde.
On voulait prouver que c'était possible de faire un film.
On en a déjà fait donc, en fait...
Faut en faire un deuxième.